[Music]  despite previous harassment allegations  against him a Netflix spokesperson has  confirmed two et Jeffrey Tambor will  appear on season five of Arrested  Development Tambor faced two accusations  of sexual harassment by members of the  transparent team in November 2017 both  claims he strongly denies three months  later Tambor announced he was exiting  his lead role on the hit Amazon series  telling ET in a statement that read in  part given the politicized atmosphere  that seems to have afflicted our set I  don't see how I can return the idea that  I would deliberately harass anyone is  simply and utterly untrue ET recently  spoke to Tambor's transparent co-star  Judith Light he spoke in to Jeffrey do  you know how he's doing I I have not  spoken to him everybody's a little  shell-shocked well let's hope because I  love this show and I would like to find  a way for it to continue because it's an  important show for television yes we we  all would most assuredly  [Music]